ochocientos sesenta y cinco personas se
han presentado como demanda civil en
este juicio histórico por el atentado
del 14 de julio del año 2016 en niza
pero podrían ser muchas más a ellos
justamente ha estado dedicado a este
primer día de un proceso histórico que
pretende extenderse por más de tres
meses histórico como el del 13 de
noviembre del 2015 que terminó hace dos
meses también en esa gran sala del
proceso será grabado para que quede para
la posteridad y el análisis en la
sociedad francesa siete son las personas
acusadas tres de ellas están privadas de
libertad uno incluso se expone a la
cadena perpetua ellos están acusados por
asociación ilícita con fines
terroristas sin embargo ninguno aparece
como coautor básicamente es porque
sabían las intenciones del autor de esta
masacre otros 4 comparecen libres son de
origen albanés y básicamente son
juzgados por sus infracciones a la ley
del porte de armas y haber ayudado
del atentado a conseguir el armamento
que llevaba en el camión las víctimas
con las que hablamos dicen que buscan
respuestas quieren saber más sobre por
qué se realizó este ataque porque
perdieron a sus seres queridos pero es
difícil justamente como no se ha
comprobado la radicalización de los
acusados que encuentren esas respuestas
al menos dicen este proceso servirá para
un reconocimiento como víctimas e
intentar pasar la página